founder of ecology which honored to have
had a paper rejected
[Applause]
first of the deeper tribution scientists
here in student systems and protocols
and in black 2 years he is one of the
essential contributors to the microlight
of practical platforms thank you very
much thank you for this prominent spot
that I am here and I feel honored to
speak after the past Turing Award
winners and maybe the future once they
come since Barbara started with a bit of
history earlier I'm gonna give a bit of
history as well here when I joined IBM
Research in around 898 ebusiness was the
big vogue of today and was what did you
have to do in those days to solve the
e-business problem I mean the company
was doing e-business and in research we
wondered what are the security problems
because after all we will cryptographers
and I have a background in cryptography
I should also say that and we have tried
to solve the fair exchange problem and
my colleagues Victor Shoup and also
Michael Viner they started looking into
how to do fair exchange because after
all that's what you want on the internet
when you do a business you I want to pay
and I want to have to good and you
should be fair and I mean this is not
what happened in practice later but they
design protocols for optimistic fair
exchange that needed a trusted third
party to resolve a dispute in case there
was a dispute in case there was no good
outcome and those protocols by the way
they look not so much different from
those other escrow protocols that you
see now in the blockchain world however
I came into the picture when we started
to wonder how to implement a distributed
more trustworthy fair exchange authority
that could resolve a dispute and that's
when we started to work on business in
agreement that's when we started to work
on fair exchange
this was the goal to to solve when we
use the threshold crypto to actually
implement this in a way that was content
to pbft and had a different background
it was also very practical yeah
and we also were working with a group in
Lisbon at the time where I think that
just to add these two to Barbara's
thoughts about Mikkel Castro the group
the team in Lisbon has a very strong
history on distributed systems and
Miguel was there before also from this
time until today actually our high perch
of fabric this is something I did at IBM
research nowadays I'm academia and I'm
looking taking a step back looking into
the problems of disability trust from
different angle ok so let's start
not you about trust because everybody
likes a different thing and you can also
not argue about security assumptions
because security assumptions can too
often not be compared with each other
and I very often been in a conference
committee or reviewing discussions where
somebody said oh this is totally not
relevant because even the because that
will not happen in practice yeah but the
mechanism giving the security
assumptions they were correct and they
solve the problem and so to say security
assumptions are very very subjective and
that's also how that that's also setting
the model for this talk here but by
large I would like to talk more about
this phenomenon of distributed trust
about what this actually is that you're
doing with blockchains and what is
behind this idea that if you just
distribute things you're going to be
more trustworthy so educated in culture
to know more the translation of where
the goes to Busan oh yeah I said you
cannot talk about trust right dad that's
what I said you cannot argue about trust
yeah that's what it means yeah okay yeah
yeah taste yeah that's what I wanted to
say in big in in the freaking way
thank you okay distributed trust now
when you ask people what is is they will
say things from Petco nice trustless and
don't trust a single null and we may be
resilient to failures and the tax and
the majority is right and there is all
there is an aspect an aspect of all of
this and this is what makes the systems
more resilient than a single node system
yeah on the other hand these distributed
systems are in a way more difficult to
secure because now you have many places
that you have too many places where you
can attack each other and since I think
that not all of you are
distributed computing people at least I
see some faces here that are in dispute
computing and many others that are also
in crypto I'm going to start with some
background on the very basic things here
to set the stage for what comes later
damn so traditionally and also earlier
and many other blockchain systems they
use this idea of threshold just the idea
that you have a number of nodes and they
vote and the votes are counted everybody
votes in the same way
so typically these are and and nodes and
there are going to be half of them that
our system wants to tolerate because
they could be faulty in this place here
they can be Byzantine faulty and as the
from from the theory it follows that if
you want to do visit Byzantine tolerant
replication in an asynchronous network
or evening in in eventually synchronous
network that has initial asynchronous
periods you need to have this n bigger
than three times F this was recognized a
long time ago but it threshold itself
depends on various other factors of the
model for example you can have faster
protocols when the world is nice then
you need a higher threshold sometimes
and this is a symmetric just I would
like to introduce the ideas behind
symmetric trust here using this model
where everybody trusts in the same way
why is it that we need n big n 3 plus F
so yeah and bigger than 3 F why what
what are examples that stand behind and
I'm going to focus on this example of
replicated storage using the register
abstraction that I will talk I will
introduce later for the benefit of those
who have not seen this basic class in
the students computing but many
protocols that come later and build
actually build on these abstractions so
in the taxes on a PV FD protocols you
have the same kind of mechanisms going
on
before I do this let me reiterate the
benefit mainly also of the crypto people
here that in distributed computing you
want a protocol to be safe and life yeah
as a crypto person me too I too often
forgot that protocols also have to be
life and liveness arguments in crypto
protocols are often like a one-liner or
don't even exist because it's sort of
supposed to be clear that this is the
case however in distribute protocols
it's clear that we need to reason
separately about liveness and safety
also because you can decompose all the
properties you want to achieve with such
protocols orthogonal e into safety and
liveness properties and famous result by
alternation either safety means that
nothing bad will happen that your
blockchain do not forc and of course if
you don't do anything then you're always
safe yeah but that's not the goal of our
systems liveness means that the protocol
actually does some work that there is
something happening where you have to
reason about executions into the future
and if you do something you're always
life but you're not necessarily safe and
so you have to understand protocols from
these two viewpoints this is very well
understood also and also if only if we
combine those two we are we are making
real progress blockchain safety here
means basically if you translate it to
blockchain that we know who owns which
coin that the ledger does not fork in
some way and that yeah and that that the
system remain maintains the consistency
itself blockchain liveness on the other
hand is this is the property of the
system response that you can execute
transactions that the market remains
fluid that's a very important thing as
well for for distributed systems for for
block chains that trade aware that there
are some some economic values attached
to coins and so on and again with
trusted central system we would
assume that we can get these things
easily with there are no failures or
attacks and the challenge is to build
and here is my favorite text book that I
will read for what comes now and so I
can recommend this if you wanted to have
more time for reading on this the basic
abstraction I want to use now for
illustrating some of the concepts in
underlying these protocols is the one of
a readwrite register so it's an
abstraction that is implemented by
distributed processes it's called a
register because originally it was
modeled in a shared memory multi
processor computer nowadays you can
think of process is talking to the cloud
you never know where it actually where
your value is stored it may be stored by
replicated system may be stored by a
blockchain for example every operation
that we do in this in this model here
though the operation the model time
operations are asynchronous operations
take time so operations have a moment
when they start model through an input
event and they have an moment when they
are complete modeled by an output event
which the protocol will generate and
between this input and output event the
operation actually takes place and this
is what we are going to reason about
as a simplification here in real world
multiple processes or nodes might be
writing and reading from such a storage
location here we're going to simplify
there is a writer or one single process
that can write and one single process
that can read this leads the so called
single writer single reader register but
you can build in a nice way that goes
back to the pioneers of distributed
computing as well you can build the more
complex abstractions from the more
primitive ones yeah so you can read you
can build emulate if you want a multi
reader multi writer arbitrary value
strong consistently strongly consistent
register from a weekly consistent single
reader single writer that only stores
bits by just using many of those
primitives together yeah so here I'm
gonna I won't just want to talk about
this model for illustrating protocols
and please do interrupt me if if
something is not clear yeah today I said
we are using this model for box chains
we all have we all have we can also
think that our block trembles like this
there are no common clocks it's this
world here is asynchronous there's also
no bound on message lays that node might
send two replicas but it's clear that in
an emulation protocol a node has to talk
to multiple replicas in order to know
what the current state of this emulated
primitive storage location is and yeah
and this this theory here in in a
beautiful work by by Morris has led to a
big under a nice understanding a very
general understanding of primitives
characterization of how powerful switch
primitives are for synchronization among
such processes the register is the most
primitive of those yeah the register is
the one that synchronizes only to
processes but from this theory that I
recommend everybody study when they were
complexion because it's relevant you can
explain why primitives like test and
side
compare-and-swap are more powerful than
the register alone yeah so a protocol
now will have the task of emulating this
storage location for us here and we have
one reader and one writer before we can
do this we need to define a few a bit
more terminology we are going to say
that in operation defined by an
invocation event and a completion event
that this operation precedes another
operation when the first operation
terminated before the second operation
was invoked so then it's clear that the
second operation takes place after even
though we have no absolute time it is
not the case in other words if the two
operations overlap in some sense and
this is in the eye of a global observer
right this this global observer is
something that we don't have available
in the product of what exists yet
otherwise if these two operations
overlapped are called concurrent and so
how should this veggies to behave when
we access it concurrently and there are
multiple consistency definitions the one
I want to focus here in here on is
regularity which is a relatively weak
condition but just to illustrate the the
terms here for those again who is now I
never seen this here is a write
operation it starts here and ends here
we write an X and here we write a Y and
it it completes here yeah and there is
another process read a first reader and
now slightly departing from my idea that
there was only one reader area there is
a first.we that actually returns the
previously written value X here and then
concurrently do this already returns
here in a read operation the value Y
here is a second reader the read one
that I'm going to focus on here the
second reader returns the value that is
being written here okay and so you might
want to why this is possible and indeed
it's possible because these two
operations they overlap so there is a
moment when some traces of this value Y
being written can already influence the
return value of this guy here this is
perfectly fine yeah
and this guy also returns
why question is now what do we ask for
the specification of this read operation
here
if the register is safe and this is
terminology going back to Lambert's
original papers on concurrent computing
as well if it's safe it means basically
nothing about a conqueror nothing
because safe the safety concept used
here only says something if the two
operations the read operation is not
concurrent to any right operation safety
actually means that you're not faulting
in that sense you're not aborting
because there is a variety operation on
going up so you can return or you can
return any value from the domain here
that's not so interesting interesting is
regular semantics of regularity where
the read client must only return the
value that has been written completely
written there before or a value that is
being written concurrently and and I'll
show an example execution where you can
see in the protocol how this may
actually occur the next step would be in
this distinction it would be atomicity
an atomic execution where all the
operations appear to take place at an
atomic moment that in the picture here
takes place between the invocation and
the completion and for this we have to
be able to put all those events in a
global sync in a globally total order
all these operations we have to be able
to put them in a global total order this
is still not as powerful as consensus
however so important here if we are
using regular semantics the red coin
can't use the old value or the one
that's being concurrently written
so when you're looking at an execution
like this here there's again the same
execution here there's a different
execution here we're here we return a
value that's not the one that most
recently written so this is not regular
however this execution here is regular
even though the current current write
returns two different operations so this
is for illustration once more and in the
protocol that is also used in mature
where the protocol comes from I do it's
definitely in intaglio and Mike's paper
on Byzantine forum systems how you
implement such a register and but it's
ideas that are very very common in and
prevalent in distributed computing the
single writer keeps a logical time stamp
and the single writer is going to use
digital signature on the timestamp and
on the value that it is going to write
yeah the writer maintains a logical time
stamp and increments these logical times
and for each operation that is going to
execute and it sends this out to the
replicated nodes the replicated nodes
are going to be any of them as I said
and F of them can be for T and F has to
be less than n over 3 and then the
writer has to wait for a Byzantine
quorum of such replicas to acknowledge
that they actually have received and
updated their local value and then the
writer can terminate and complete its
write operation and the Byzantine quorum
here is defined in this model as n + f /
- strictly more than n plus F over 2
which translates to 2 F + 1 if F if n is
equal to 3 F plus 1 if you run with
maximum resonance the reader also asks
all the replicas for if a reader can
come at any time concurrent to the right
yeah the reader asks for all the
replicas for their current values and
their times them value pairs and the
reader will get such times and value
pairs from a quorum again from a
Byzantine column or Byzantine
dissemination column as it was called by
by Dario and Mike Reider and it extracts
after verifying the signatures the value
with
highest time stamp em and return step
questions in the 930 this is the idea of
annoyed or less right right if you
replace visiting poems with regular
terms this is just mapping between
shared memory and message boxes I showed
in the bottom and a beedi paper URL
you're saying no okay okay
there is no linearize ability here in
this protocol this is regular this is
Chiefs regular semantics only not doing
linearize ability okay okay
well basically in filter and depends on
what you call the Byzantine filter ins
I'm using the term Byzantine fault
tolerance for whatever tasks you can do
to tolerate Byzantine faults not only
state machine replication as the work of
halloween-ween shows more is that if you
have or consensus among them you can
replicate any data structure like this
if you only have if you don't have that
then you can replicate at least register
without any other other semantics like
this yeah this is weaker in in in one
model this is strictly much weaker yeah
because this protocol itself is a little
building block inside pbft for example
and inside other protocols protocols of
this sort yeah so that's why I'm showing
this to you here because it's a building
block that shows up in many places yeah
looks like so this one here regular
distance allow the second week to return
and even after the first week yes yes
that's exactly what the point I'm going
to get across and I will have an
execution that shows how this happens
here after I give you now I'm going to
show you the execution here is a lot of
arrows here but you can see again here
the right of the X followed by the right
of Y and it's now only one client
reading and let's see if there's a lie a
point occurs later lasers or not yeah
this client here receives an answer from
client from from replica T after replica
t already stores the newest timestamp
the higher timestamp so this client here
in this case will actually return Y the
newly written value here here we've
writing right it may be the case that it
up it executes another read operation
later and because we didn't do it would
be simple defend against dispatches
buffering a lot the highest time stamp
but this is something that comes later
if we're just looking at well because
the network here might respond in
arbitrary ways it can also get in the
second read operation it can get
responses that are from the Byzantine
guy who will respond with an value that
it has been properly signed but it is at
its deliberation what it wants to sign
and these two other processes who have
not yet seen the update yeah until this
one here actually reaches the processor
the note queue even after the operation
terminal but the operation here
terminated this is not shown after
receiving receiving acknowledgments
again from three this is four processes
the minimum DFT system that makes sense
in a way okay and then and then yes of
course if you are running the read
operation invoking it off to the right
terminate you must get the most recently
with nine okay yes that's that's the
illustration of this I want it like I
wanted to show you a high level the yes
operations and at the end here this dot
you mean this is when the writer gets an
acknowledgement message from a quorum
from Byzantine quorum of replicas that
acknowledge to it that they actually
have stored after of the dis this and
this guy here again and the protocol is
shown not wait here yeah so this is how
the pseudocode will look like in all of
those text books basically the writer
will willing in increment its timestamp
and it will ask it will send this out to
the replicas the replicas will do if
they're if a newer timestamp arrives the
wrap because will update what they store
locally and then they will send this ACK
message back to the right that the
writer will wait for more than n plus F
over 2 which is the Byzantine quorum or
Byzantine dissemination quorum we are
using signatures here and then it will
terminate right here yeah and the reader
has a similar protocol where it's going
to extract them from its received
answers one that comes with the highest
time stamp and this this current is what
we want and this is at the heart of all
those BFT or Byzantine tolerant
algorithms yeah okay
more questions oh we actually I did we
talked about this yeah this is the
alternative so these are Byzantine
dollar and protocols in the threshold
model we need usually we need food for
this model here and at least strictly
more than three F processes or notes to
make this life to tolerate f4d notes and
we can do many tasks like this that have
names like broad cost primitives
consistent broadcast consensus state
machine duplication or block chains if
you work in the permission block similar
look so that was setting the stage for
the DFT and consensus algorithms with
symmetric Chester now to iterate here in
this model that I showed that I now
already done all the nodes have the same
trust assumption so they cannot they've
been told what the many ways of the day
yeah in terms of taste yeah they did not
choose their own trust their own trust
at all the notes here are equally
trusted because it's symmetric even it's
actually more because all the nodes that
doesn't make anything model does not
make any distinction between nodes that
might be more reliable or more powerful
or more secure than others and all the
nodes trust equally so there's these two
properties and already in the 90s this
was generalized by Dario and Mike and
also concurrently by two so-called
generalized or Byzantine quorum systems
where now we can specify arbitrary full
sets initially instead of a saying that
any set of two might fail we can specify
a fail prone system or a fault structure
well in this example here we could say
we have two sets here and any of any two
of those above here might fail or any
two of those down here but it's sort of
a bipartite situation where we can't
have a situation where one of those up
here and one of those up down here fail
at the same time and this is very well
understood from the theory of from that
theory of Byzantine Coulomb systems
exactly exactly here right and by Dario
and Mike as well that's what I'm saying
I'm just saying that exists right
I think yeah okay let's not get into
this discussion they sir
I think the I've talked to both people
and and the work was independent these
are these are the journal versions that
took that will publish years of the day
first to publish these ideas it's I
think it's fair to say that even though
they did not understand each other at
the time here we don't talk about
synchrony Roy synchrony at all
here we are abstracting away or I I
recall the abstraction that was used
that can be used in the protocol that I
have shown before to replace the
Byzantine quorum notion of n bigger than
2f as that of the number of acts that I
need the messages that I need to receive
that was had to be bigger than n plus F
over 2 so you can receive a quorum of
such responses yeah
if you define the quorum system like
this and I'll talk about the definition
of the quorum system in a moment the
definition of the quorum system is
derived from the failed prone system
here the fail prone system is first of
all you specify who you want to tolerate
as possible other sizes and notice that
there are six nodes here so you cannot
have n bigger than 3f right because
there are only six and two of them might
be faulty but of course we don't have
all possible none of the two none of
them none of them we don't talk about
protocols here these protocols these
notions make sense once you talk about
asynchronous protocols like the protocol
I shown before which is the example from
from from from the Byzantine column
systems paper yeah we've actually one of
them here and then then the set here are
going to be quorums in this model and
notice now compared to the threshold
trust model not all nodes or equally
trusted anymore we have certain notes
that play a bigger role
in a certain way and other notes that
play a lesser role not all notes are
trusted in a symmetric way but all notes
trust in same way in this picture all
notes use the same trust assumption
if all of us treat this set in the same
way then if I remember there is out
there the results earth-days in the same
way that you have served in the clash of
model every three bed sets shouldn't
cover the whole the only second excited
thank you for for for looking ahead this
is this actually is an amazing
ingredient in this model here and a
consequence of the definitions that I'm
repeating here that you can show such
column systems exist if and only if you
don't have any three bad sets that
covered all three sets of bad notes that
cover the whole space yeah so it has to
be an extra one generalizing on the
condition that n has to be bigger than
three F yeah and so here you have again
a consistency definition which
translates into safety that each every
two quorums must intersect in a set that
contains not only for tea parties for
any set of faulty parties and an
availability condition that says for
each set of corrupted parties for tea
parties that must exist the corn that is
joined of them because in our protocols
we will usually rely on such a quorum to
tell me something and I'm progressing
when a sponsor quorum tells me something
definitely the protocol I've shown you
before was of this kind where I'm
reading from the register and I wait for
a quorum and this is the same column
here that works so this is the model of
symmetric just okay so what about a
symmetric trust and this is the sub the
topic I want to get to in this talk now
what happens if each node now specifies
its own fault sets its own fault
assumptions in the same way as before
yeah so I think that two of those might
be faulty and three of those and you
have another different assumption who
might be faulty and who might know who
might be correct and as for illustration
here we have again six nodes and this is
the fail prong set the failed prong
specification of node P that has two
neighbors in the ring here its neighbors
are more trustworthy because he is close
to them so it says
pew and all might fail independently of
it or might fail
there could be possible failures but Q&R
don't fail together and QR q and all
when they fail they don't fail with one
of the other so the failed prone system
here contains Q and R as potential
singleton sets and of the remote ones
it's the same situation as before maybe
two of them can fail I want to be
prepared that two of them can fail so
this is now a fail prone system that P
alone would specify and the asymmetric
trust arises when we let each node
specify a trust assumption like this if
if each node would specify a trust
assumption again like this but from his
point of view correspondingly rotated we
get what we call an asymmetrical quorum
system that I will design define shortly
I was just looking at this we all know
we know each other's we know the trusted
yes in this picture we know the trusted
we know that's right yeah the
specification does not say something
about crashes or not the specification
says something about potential failure
but it will it's clear that we're going
to use it for Byzantine columns later
I'm in peace until failure right I don't
specifically call them Byzantine
asymmetric here but here now that we
have we have relaxed this other
condition that each node can now trust
differently not only are the nodes
trusted differently they all trust
differently and that now takes up ideas
that come from blockchain space and that
actually is the reason why I'm talking
about this in the blockchain workshop
and also the reason why I'm looking at
this in the first place so ripple
introduce the ideas like this in about
2012
not long after of the Bitcoin came out
it's the third in mark
cap there is a ripple consensus
algorithm that was specified in a white
paper that doesn't exist in a clearly
understandable form according to my own
this my statement other than in the code
itself and I'll show you some of the
other and work on this later
but the main feature of this is that
each node in the Republic chain will
declare other nodes that it trusts and
basically in the protocol it means it's
all the nodes from which it receives and
processes votes if a node votes that is
not on its trust list and this trust
list is the so-called unique node list
the node just drops the message on the
Floria and they intend to achieve some
notion of Byzantine fault tolerant
consensus and that's what you can read
here in the documentation these nodes
are trusted validators in the unique
node list and that's that's actually
where who you trust
subjective trust yeah in vapor means
that each node receives and processes
votes only from a certain subset there's
a statement on the succession the comp
the talk is going to go on and I think
Elly is going to give the talk next
often so the two nodes must overlap the
two you announce the two node lists must
overlap but by how much and that's this
and what nodes can fail and what happens
to the system here's another example
this is from the white paper in 2014
they said oh the two node lists that you
and I might have they should overlap in
in 20% of the maximum of the size of our
lists and this was something that
everybody who looks at this and know
something about the other column says by
20% is not strictly bigger so we don't
know how this comes going and also there
were multiple people looking at this the
white paper said must be doable that
must be 20% a paper by arcanist and I
think some others that whose name I
forgot names I forgot unfortunately
proof there must be at least 40% there
was another white paper that is an
archive by authors a triple that came
out last year they did I said the
overlap must be at Lee almost a hundred
percent and and the paper hasn't been
really peer-reviewed because it's it's
still an archive and the two authors
have actually left with at least one of
them to who I who I traced anyway it
here's the example from this paper here
where they say you can lose life nests
even if you have almost complete overlap
of the to trust sets of the true uun
else and in my lab now I have some
people looking at ripple at the code and
we engineering and we are convinced that
even with a hundred percent overlap we
can get stuck in this in this protocol
but we haven't been able to formalize
this yet
what happens today is that ripple
publish is a signed list of recommended
alla tears and validators and disabled
people user today there are 31 note here
but it's inherently difficult to test
such systems in the sense because it's
not some some attack that you can just
run on your own on the basement this is
something that you would have to control
a substance substantial set of notes or
you simulate the whole mental okay
stellar is what you wanted to mention
right so stellar evolved as enable
evolved as as in stellar evolved as a
fork of ripple originally and then the
protocol okay
then they have some issues with the
ripple protocol I don't know why I
suspect they were trying to run it with
some actual adversaries but then at the
protocol which we designed from scratch
by David Mercier and it was documented
in my paper that's been on the stellar
website and it achieves a notion that is
called federated quorum a federated
fault-tolerant consensus federated
Byzantine consensus this notion is is
what I'm going to talk about a bit now
this is the original thing which an
don't want to talk about but these
quorum slices in the stellar
architecture or the stellar white paper
where the code responds to a statement
that is asserted by a quorum if the
quorum says this is what I should do
like this is the value I should read I
go I proceed in the protocol yeah so and
here is a notion of a somatic just as
well where each node declares its own
set of such slices or such
nodes that can assert a statement to
this other node and then a set of such
slices that is closed under this
operation that it can be convinced by a
set by a slice that is also part of this
set is called a quorum
however the relation of this work to the
literature on consensus is not clear to
me and I think also not clear to several
others hold on hold on
here is an example I talked to Julia on
the last week right okay so here is an
example of a stellar quorum that's from
the documentation on the website here at
the top level you have again five nodes
but two nodes of them are virtual nodes
that can be fulfilled by a threshold of
other nodes where various conditions
have to hold and then you can think of a
possible fault set that this actually
induces yeah but this is how they're
going to be configured with such
symmetric trust notions at the end of
the day it's not but we've actually
threshold trust notions in a certain way
for this level so that's actually a
picture from the life system I
understand there was something that
happened recently in the stellar system
where researchers from Korea looked at
the trust graph and they plotted this
picture here about the trust graph
showing the more trustworthy trusted
nodes in the system with fatter with
bigger circles and the less trusted one
with smaller circles and they showed a
certain said centralization in this
network this maybe they'll be
unavoidable I think if you want to
actually reach consensus but this is
actually what what they would they
showed and would also happen in that as
a sort of consequence of this maybe is
that ripple a stellar started to
reconfigure its trust graph this is how
I read it and then they had an issue
where the network actually stalled
because not enough nodes were alive
this can happen of course in any PFD
system if you violate the assumption but
it shows somehow that it's not so clear
that what goes on in last week there was
yeah but the I think that the promise
that that paper by Carol didn't
distinguish failure safety from danger
wideness but the consequences are
extremely different so if you look at
what actually happened on we have but
imagine if like big pointed taken sixty
seven minutes to like monitor something
people wouldn't even know blinked right
so it's like yeah it was bad we had the
have like intervention but no there's no
like money lost or anything no I don't
know I mean never definitely human
intervention was needed but also if you
if you take a pbft style system and you
you don't have enough nodes that are
there you can lose liveness rate as well
but it's much much less serious than the
loss of TC particularly if your protocol
allows you to recover from the loss of
blackness right I agree that life and
it's your big trouble if you get 67
minutes of downtime it's not great but
you know wire transfers take 24 hours
now anyway okay okay I agree that that
lightness is often not as serious as as
safety violations however I think we
want to understand how they go together
symmetric keys you have to consider them
separately because it could be that you
want your fault points for safety to be
much much higher than your fault
that may be a separate discussion for
which we which we okay yes basically
finds quorum slices but my reading of
the paper was that if you move to a
decision if you actually observe
signatures from a fool card not just the
slice you trust is that true or not
you move you don't just wait for you
Cory according slides to say okay you
have to wait for a full quorum that
contains your coordinates lies to say
okay right okay another way of that
i-i-i think i responded to what i traced
in the protocol and the paper presents
next week it just okay so there's a
paper here from the one thing is that
that's slightly counterintuitive if
you've been in the area for a while is
there really a quorum is a property of a
set of messages constellar it's not a
property of a set of nodes because you
might change your form slices and so
that goes against our intuition about
these problems okay I'm gonna have an
answer that there's actually in line
with her intuition about how we think of
our quorums in the past here is an
answer that was given last week at the
disc conference in the formalization of
a personal Byzantine quorum system and
and the thing that's sort of striking
here and is a technical difference
between the existing column systems and
this formalization here is that we
define quorums knowing who are they
actually faulty parties in an execution
yeah so we define we first assume a
faulty set of nodes and then we said we
have a set of nodes that are correct and
for each of those correct nodes we're
going to have this property here
asserted namely that yeah I'm gonna not
gonna pause this I'm going to leave this
leave this for the later discussion that
that you're going to put out yeah
however what I understand from this is
if you instantiate this notion of quorum
with symmetric just you don't get the
notion that Malkin writer had in the
paper it's a different notion in the
sense and that's why I want to leave
lead you to this other notion in the net
in the last 10-15 minutes it does not
give a Byzantine quorum systems this
mathematics here says it does it's a
it's a different viewpoint I think this
is you can know you could get an
approximation of a quorum and over
something you know is a form but there
may be forms that you don't know about
so the word columns gets us thinking
about things that may not be the case
here so let's look at asymmetrical rooms
well then we don't know but we still
have to be protected against them right
yeah but they might vote to me but they
might not vote to send sent the same
boat over there it's exactly what you
want to prevent against yeah okay coming
back to a sim to this this world here so
an asymmetric column system is a quorum
system that starts from the assumptions
of failed prong sets but each process
now specifies each node specifies its
own failed prong sets each on each note
has its own subjective trust assumption
he expressed in terms of faulty sensor
according to the process node P I here
all of those in its own faulty set might
be failure faulty at some time and an
asymmetric quorum system consists simply
of an array of a quorum system a
traditional type symmetric column system
for each participant but now we have n
processes that each has a separate
column system and there was there is a
condition here that each two quorums
have to overlap in a well in a set of
nodes that does not include only nodes
that I considered to be 40 and that you
consider before
because we don't have the same trust
assumptions obviously so there's to be
some other node that is correct for both
of us and availability is only per
process only per note each node for each
node in its own column system and it's
according to its fault assumption that
has to exist a quorum that is not
intersect with its fault assumption
these are not teaser there's a QJ too
much here oh okay
there should be a QJ yes thank you all
the stars is the the set of subsets of
that because you might not have you
might not have a common set here yeah
but otherwise the notion here is maximum
maximum for the maximum size and this
goes actually back to to a paper that
was even before Satoshi started to think
about block chains where this this
originally comes from but this was never
formulated in put into context of the
distributed computing literature in the
past so earlier on you mentioned that
someone mentioned that there is this
property that I call q3 property
according to hit Maori which means that
in the symmetric property a symmetric
column system no three fault
sets must cover all nodes this
generalizes the statement at three F has
to be strictly less than n and here is a
property that are not going to read but
it generalizes the property for this
property to a symmetric just that there
must be enough nodes in the system that
are trusted by others by by you and by
me and if this condition holds for all
pairs of nodes then this is an
asymmetric column system and from this
thing now we can build protocols iam
there's a theorem that says that
symmetric column systems exist if and
only if these q3 property holds and we
have a theorem that says these a
symmetric column systems exist if and
only if these be three property here
holds and with this property now we can
go back to our protocols and generalize
them for a symmetric model and the nice
thing is that these protocols
work exactly as the protocols we have
seen before here actually yes example
for intuition because it seems like all
the properties that matter
I can have my subjective you know
personal forces you should give to have
yours but all the properties this matter
should actually holds for both of us so
I have all these beliefs and yeah yeah
they don't really can you get some
intuition of an example where it really
is not three F plus one or some weighted
oh just the neighbors here for example I
trust my neighbors more than the people
who are living across the street you
don't you and I are in the same system
yeah you trust you now you're up here
you trust in a different way here right
and this this this shows that this is
going to be a quorum system if all the
six nodes trust like this in a symmetric
rotated way this is going to be a quorum
system and we can run PDF DNA we just
out now enables more than our remote
friends for example yes oh this comes
this comes in a second again this is not
some example you can get us as a
generalization of threshold trust this
is always what who has to pay attention
for yeah so when the system actually
runs then they're going to be faulty
notes Byzantine notes and now as a new
element and this is of this is also in
in the other systems like this if you
have a note that now makes okay there
are forty notes these are the notes in
the set F yeah and then there are
correct notes all the other nodes are
correct but some of them are naive
because they made a wrong trust
assumption and some of them are correct
or wise because they made the right
trust assumption in the sense that
they're the actually faulty part is the
actual fault set was foreseen by them
yeah and the notion again that that I
think is a found Ennis in a similar way
in the stellar formalization here that
the nodes that made the right choices
are called by
and simple examples will convince you
that they can guarantee properties that
we want from such protocols only for
device processes the know if one's might
have the wrong friends and they're
talking to the wrong people so they can
be cheated yeah even if they're correct
yeah so there with this we're going to
be able to say that the vise processes
are safe and life they are not always
life because in some cases we need the
assumption of what we call a guilt and a
guild here is a set of wise notes that
will contain a quorum for each of the
member notes again this seems a bit
related to the stellar notion but it's
it's technically not the same slices is
just the distributed way to define the
code that you are talking about
everybody's unsecured here through the
period calling in Stella
but in Stella you just the specification
is implementable not some I don't agree
with that the fact that this this this
disappears in the standard protocol yeah
here is the algorithm that I had before
with symmetric threshold columns we wait
for n plus F for more than n plus M over
2 this is the register implementation
and you can go to generalize Byzantine
columns by replacing this with a quorum
yeah this was in the monkey right paper
and if you look at asymmetric columns we
replace those with the subjective
columns for the process that runs this
operation yeah so here the writer waits
for a quorum for itself of responses and
the reader writes for a quorum of acts
no not acts for a quorum of values for
itself
yeah and if the reader and the right are
both wise in that formulation then they
will be consistent they will satisfy the
specifications of the register I yeah
now Eve notes is a new element because
they don't exist otherwise
okay and then we there in the paper and
in an upcoming paper we have a couple of
protocols that can be derived simply by
taking the existing protocols and
replacing quorums like this it's not
straight totally straightforward because
one has to get to the notions like this
but the protocols will look very similar
to the existing protocol the protocol is
actually are as I showed before just
replacing the quorums that symmetric
forums by the asymmetric columns but
then some many such protocols have
notions of you need F +1 processes to do
something right and then this is going
to be different depending there
different way to generalize this yeah
because f plus 1 in the model with N
equals 3 F plus 1 this can be a set that
is called a core set in some old papers
that contains at least one correct
process but it can also be a process a
set that the V and others in the past
have called a kernel that actually
overlaps with each quorum yeah so the
correct thing for example for this for
this brocco broadcast which is a call
primitive that shows up in a way in pbft
and in other systems is to use the
kernel for this abstraction these
protocols don't really look different
from the other protocol so when you send
this actually sent this to the
conference in this real computing that
people say oh the protocols are the same
as before so why should I care and I
think this is exactly the point that
that this exactly the point that the
protocols look the same because we want
the protocols to be the same there's
just much more powerful now because they
can they can work with subjective trust
with these different justice objects I
think that's about it
I thought I wanted to say and I thank
you for your attention and I'm taking
for the questions
[Applause]
as you said we would take any
traditional particle simulation that you
actually have to do all those proofs in
a certain way again because there's no
general composition theorem that that I
have for the moment here in my in my
understanding I don't know you might
have a different we don't give you know
they don't give a guarantee we don't
give a guarantees they might well exist
we have to we have to derive what
guarantees that you actually get yes I
guess this is more I believe in a
question but it these systems now a loss
of safety can literally be like ten
orders of magnitude more expensive than
a loss and so basically like I think
when you're talking about this you
should never say like use the letter F
right you should always use F sub s and
F sub L but one is like you're sure
you're both hearts your tolerance for
liveness and then how you translate
things it actually matters when you're
saying we'll just replace F plus one
with this whatever actually matters
whether you're talking about FS or some
models like the store model where you
have both the membership there really is
no such equipment there's there's an
equivalent to an F cosine set of size F
L plus one there is no
besides a set of size FS plus one this
is one of the reasons why you inherently
I believe need an extra round of
communication okay I understand the
point about different quantum systems
different failed proton assumptions Fred
prone systems for safety in liveness
this is something that has been done and
exercised and explored for the last 20
years at least in the first decade of
the last 20 years by a lot of people and
I think this is this is now calling for
more work on this but initially I would
like to understand how it works when say
when this distrust assumption is the
same for safety in lightning but I think
the point is well-taken yeah that is
something that should come and I don't
know I mean many of their actual systems
that we see out there in the blockchain
space they do not distinguish those two
parameters okay we have the corset so
essentially these that you know personal
or decentralized following systems
saying that I have my setup sets you
have your set of sets forever on
importance is there any and everybody
else's right theory that you couldn't do
right by just saying let's just take
unions of forms so clearly every two of
my quorums intersect in something that's
not contained by what I believe is the
filters that are in your sense do not
intersect in something that's
what you believe is fearful and so now
every union of one of your upon one of
mine take two storms or foe prevail
princess every to fail Princesa quorums
a super quorum which another one that
may exist that's that's a good question
yes verification made a lot of progress
is last years and a lot of automated
methods can deal with X plus 1 n minus F
expressions so what is your feeling
about the world in abstractions that
work first one perhaps definitely but
you have to handle the complexity of
exponentially many sets if you have n
nodes are going to be you need to be
able to specify our fail prone system
right you don't want to enumerate all
the sets because they're going to be
exponentially mean so you want to have a
more compact way of doing those and
looking at the existing systems is a
good start for this so I think I think
that the syntax that I showed earlier
about the stellar config file it's
already a good start but you need to
have a handle for this you need you
can't simply just enumerate
we are Pataki save it I mean even in the
northern replication so the 42 is though
they hit some F plus one and then to
figure out exo-m's that is a plus one
actually me something about
intersections right yeah I hope the
network model is not not different from
75% of the work in the digital computing
area where V is when we talk about
resilience and fault tolerance here
where we assume full connectivity the
celery model is also a kind of aircraft
potentially not before
which might result in nodes which are
another way of not aware of that I
thought the stellar model would have
full would assume full connectivity in
some sense oh yeah
able to reach a core abroad so what what
actually is different in the
cryptocurrency space and in the in the
blockchain space from the papers in pbft
and systems papers that followed it and
also our older papers is that we don't
use point-to-point connections between
nodes which is gossip the net the
messages necessarily this means we are
going to use public key signatures
instead of point-to-point authentication
that what that's what the people frowned
upon in the past because they thought
that it's way too slow to people use
public key signatures but I if you if
you compare the time that the signature
operation takes its minuscule compared
to the latency on the internet and the
scalable communication through the
gossip networks is is a big plus that
these systems now have added which is
not the same that was very cool so in
that sense communication model differs a
bit yeah
but you still have to know there are the
note so you still have to know you have
to be able to verify signature from
another so I guess we'll have the rest
of them we have lunch
[Applause]